pourquoi vouloir continuer le projet
irréaliste des bêtes déjà une première
chose c'est que ce projet là puisqu'il
pose question nous avons nous sommes
engagés à faire en sorte qu'il puisse
être remis sur la table
données les données factuelles par ce
qui en fait en ce moment il ya beaucoup
de chiffres qui circulent et c'est donc
on a besoin de remettre transparence
connaissance maîtrise du dossier pour
que les habitants entendent les enjeux
de ce dossier là ce dossier là c'est
lutter contre l'étalement urbain c'est
proposer des logements avec une
diversification du type d'habit terres
d'habitat
c'est aussi prendre soin la biodiversité
aux écoulements d'eau sud deux au
superficiel mois nous avons des enjeux
importants sur ce dossier là anne vignot
il mettra sur l'agréable construire
howett ou pas je dis que ce dossier là
il est nécessaire que l'on puisse
construire le long du tram
mais ce dossier là il sera mis sur la
table pour que tout le monde comprenne
quels sont les enjeux et comment on le
fera on va soumettre ce dossier là à des
scientifiques aux citoyens et on
regardera très clairement comment lutter
contre je le redis l'étalement donc ça
amènera des constructions ça amènera des
aménagements de ce dossier là et ça
amènera ce que ce dossier là soit
compatible avec les enjeux du 21e siècle
la biodiversité
la question de l'eau et la question de
la qualité de vie ça amènera des
constructions donc si vous êtes maire
dimanche vous construirez howett
si on met gros gros prennent bien je dis
je le redis sur un certain nombre de
secteurs de cet endroit là on devra
construire si toutefois demain les
scientifiques me disent ce n'est pas
possible parce qu'en fait on ne peut pas
rendre compatible la construction et la
biodiversité de ce secteur
mais encore une fois on ne pense pas
l'urbanisme à partir d'un seul quartier
je suis géographe
j'ai travaillé sur l'environnement
depuis des années et donc on travaillera
en connaissance de cause
monsieur fagots question de paul émile
quel sera le coût de votre projet terra
maison sur howett sur le projet terra
maison sio qu'on a chiffré à 5 millions
d'euros
c'est quand même une question
fondamentale que cette question des
aides j'ai toujours pas compris vraiment
la réponse de madame vigneault en gros
la réponse et les binaires voulez-vous
bétonné ou ne pas bétonner les bêtes
aujourd'hui
bonjour aujourd'hui je gagne c'est
différent je ne sais pas ce qu'il en est
sur notre projet terra maison sur moi je
suis très à l'aise parce qu'en plus
c'est une question qui me passionne
vraiment ce qui se passe sur les met
donc moi je refuse on a toujours refusé
cette bétonisation sur les bêtes qui a
été porté par les par les élus de la
majorité sortante juste derrière juste
pour remettre les chiffres sur les jours
donne la parole pour préciser on parle
de 7 hectares constructibles sur 23
hectares aujourd'hui 24 opposé voilà
donc à peu près 30% constructive je vous
redonne la parole
donc en fait si vous voulez sur ce
projet térabits anciaux donc on est très
à l'aise parce qu'aujourd'hui nous on
veut vraiment arrêter ce projet donc de
bétonisation des bêtes on a toujours été
constant et cohérent par rapport à notre
engagement là dessus et ensuite c'est de
pouvoir faire en sorte de développer une
ferme urbaine avec une production locale
et de travailler sur ce qu'on a appelé
nous cette cité durable c'est y étiez
durable avec des espaces pédagogiques
avec des espaces éducatifs pour les dix
ont initié la petite ferme qui existent
ne connaît très bien le secteur n'ont
pas si vous l'avez deviné fagots jeu
juste terminée par un portrait de madame
vigneault je viens de vous complétez
votre réponse parce que lors de la
conférence de presse commune avec
alexandre accords dits oui si donc la
république en marge qui vous a rallié au
cours de il ya quelques jours au futur
effectivement alexandra cordier est
résolument favorable à la construction
de l'écoquartier
vous avez dit lors de cette conférence
de presse finalement nos positions sont
très proches avec alexandra cordier donc
je suis un peu surpris itéra bezons sûr
vous ne parlez pas de logement il n'ya
pas le mot logement dans votre projet
est ce que vous vous construisez ou
est-ce que ce projet là c'est de
l'affichage
alors si vous voulez par rapport au
soutien qu'alexandra cordier m'apporter
apporte à notre liste besançon
maintenant vous l'aurez constaté ce
n'est pas une fusion de listes
tout simplement c'est un soutien et nul
besoin aujourd'hui d'être d'accord sur
tout pourquoi reporter un projet un
projet commun rapport à cela vous
construisez nul besoin d'être d'accord
sur tout pour pouvoir construire un
projet commun demain vous l'avez bien
constater aujourd'hui nous ce que nous
voulons collectivement c'est de faire
rayonner besançon et par rapport à la
construction
oui il y aura du développement donc de
l'habitation raisonnée parce que là
dessus et moi j'ai toujours
j'ai toujours été très claire par
rapport par rapport à ça et non pas des
immeubles comme madame pinault voudrait
pouvoir développer sur sur le secteur
des bêtes mais derrière si vous voulez
aujourd'hui alexandra qu'en dites vous
questionné par rapport à cela alexandre
accordé apporte son soutien parce
qu'aujourd'hui entre le pragmatisme elle
déraisonnable d'un côté entre si vous
voulez le renouveau et la décroissance
je crois qu'aujourd'hui même cordier a
choisi le pragmatisme et le renouveau
eric alauzet lundi la semaine dernière
sur ce plateau vous avez été le plus
clair sur les bêtes vous avez dit oui il
faut construire parce que sinon on
envoie les nouveaux habitants à la
périphérie
le problème c'est que c'est pas votre
programme monsieur à l'oser votre
programme s'est tiré au sort des
citoyens qui décideront parce que les
politiques et les experts
considérez-vous sont disqualifiés est-ce
que vous prêchez levier l'avis que
rendra la convention citoyenne que vous
souhaiter convoquer j'ai une petite idée
de ce qui peut en sortir
sur le fond moi j'ai ma vision du
territoire
il faut partir du projet existant qui a
été travaillée qui ne s'occupent que 30
% de l'espace
il faut l'améliorer par ce qu'il s'est
passé quinze ans mais ma responsabilité
de maire c'est de proposer des logements
de qualité aux habitants des logements
qualitatif écologique avec des espaces
privatifs terrasse rez-de-jardin ouvert
sur la nature des espaces logement qui
respire sinon les habitants vont partir
à la périphérie et c'est pas parce qu'on
a des logements vides à besançon qui
sont malheureusement pas qualitatif
toujours peut pas toujours les rénover
sont dans des quartiers ou mal configuré
les gens veulent pas forcément il y
aller la preuve c'est que on a stagné au
niveau des habitants à besançon s'est
accru à la périphérie
déjà on est déjà en difficulté alors que
dijon a réparti ses habitants entre la
périphérie et le centre ville
donc c'est extrêmement important de
construire mais de bonne qualité voilà
donc mon projet est très claire après la
convention citoyenne c'est pour arriver
à un consensus
merci
finalement nous sommes très proches les
trois parce que ce que j'entends qu'il
ya de la construction sur les vaches
allaitantes vous discutiez avec verdi
temps d'installation d'une production
agricole en vous discuté avec les
habitants de symbole
ils sont ils sont pas contre les
constructions à rien si on avance et on
a compris on a compris mais vos
positions sont très nuancée à tous et
d'autres justifier sur ses justifier
leurs éléments très concrets
c'est qu'aujourd'hui vous avez quand
même votre numéro 36 de votre liste qui
dit clairement il faut bétonner les
lettres puisqu'il s'est exprimée par
rapport à cela et il dit très clairement
que les bêtes se le projet des bêtes
c'est de l'écologie champ m enfin je
crois qu'à un moment donné il va falloir
comment bien on avance je voulais dans
ce débat